you know for how long queer audiences
have been asking for more representation
and for how long conservative audiences
have been complaining about it you'd
think we'd have gotten further along in
terms of normalizing it by now wouldn't
you
[Music]
hey folks it's been a while since i've
taken queer representation as a broad
topic
so let's do that this time i'm gonna be
addressing in a way sort of the question
of
why is the instances of representation
and the quality the duration just
why is the progress so slow
why are we still at a point where we're
begging for crumbs of just an
acknowledgement that queerness exists at
all much less a well-fleshed out
character when it comes to most major
franchises and massive releases
well
there's
a number of reasons actually
now um i'm going to be breaking this
down into sort of four primary things
that i want to focus on and talk about
some of which i've actually talked about
before some of which i haven't one i
don't think i've seen really anybody
address but occurred to me that like i
feel like that's in the mix
i'll tell you what i'm not going to
dwell on though
and that's the question of morality and
what i mean by that is anyone who's
going to make the decision
to either include or not include queer
representation when that decision is
being made by a large entertainment
company the likes of sony warner
brothers disney paramount etc
morals do not enter into this so i'm not
going to get into the weeds of saying
well maybe they believe it is morally
correct to include something like that i
don't think that's part of anybody's
process
companies by and large are amoral
entities and by amoral i mean just a
lack of morals they don't have them and
that pendulum kind of swings in all
directions sometimes it means they'll do
the right thing because they have no
reason to think that that's the wrong
thing to do sometimes they will fail to
do the right thing because it being the
right thing does not carry weight
inherently now nobody get into instances
of like what about this company or that
company basically any company that isn't
run by a single individual or like a
family
morals aren't the question here if it's
run by a board if it's run by a ceo who
doesn't own a majority share and hasn't
like didn't like found the company
themselves morals aren't into this the
most that morals enter into any
company's calculus on whether or not to
include something like queer
representation only goes as far as how
does the inclusion or lack of inclusion
affect our image
and the impression that we have morals
that is as close as they come to caring
about the moral value of whether or not
it's good to include representation is
whether or not the image of having
morals is in their interest
and that is so shallow that i'm just not
going to dwell on it so this is me
explaining why that's not something that
we're adding into the mix
there are however as i said four major
areas that i think do impact
the frequency the degree and the depth
for lack of a better way to put it of
the representation that we are or aren't
getting and i am going to be looking at
this in the way that i believe these
corporations look at it i'm not going to
say that this is the way they should be
looking at it but again we're not
getting into a moral thing here this is
just me analyzing
why we are in the situation we're in
first thing that they need to take into
account is
the risk or benefit of audience appeal
versus audience alienation and the
metric on that is pretty simple
is the gain of new audience or the
solidifying loyalty of an existing
audience worth more to us
if we include queer representation than
the potential loss of audience from
whatever audience members we alienate by
doing this
and that is honestly this fairly
standard metric that most of these
things are measured by do we get more
than we lose again this is pretty much
all on paper until they actually put it
into practice they can guess and try and
calculate what will or won't work out
best for them and for the most part
these companies are usually pretty good
about that they get it wrong sometimes
and boy
have i been known to call it out when
they do but that's a pretty standard
metric and that's a metric that these
kinds of companies have been doing for
ever i mean you can go back to the 70s
it's why so many tv shows shifted away
from
rural shows and things set and meant to
appeal to a more rural conservative
audience to start appealing to audiences
in more urban areas and in cities it was
strictly demographic because
broadly speaking
the audience that lived in cities
usually had more money to spend making
them more valuable to advertisers than
appealing to people who lived in more
rural and or more uh depressed areas
so
i'm not gonna get into the history of
that but like there was a shift in the
set in the 60s and 70s with all this and
there's a reason for it and it's the
same kind of thing just played out and
played forward and this is an area that
for a while at least it seemed pretty
clear-cut uh the majority
of people just by most polls
believe that
queer people have a right to exist and
believe that queer rights are a good
thing and so
it is now at a point where
it should be
safe
to appeal to these audiences whereas
before appealing to a queer audience
really did put you at risk especially in
decades previous
now
for a while i would say through most of
2010s that seemed like a no-brainer you
weren't going to lose much
now as far as that metric goes as time
has gone on and queer people have
recent
massive legislative pushback in certain
areas of the country notwithstanding by
and large queer people and their
presence has been
more accepted
and seen as something that
is fine and so it has started to become
safe for companies to start to appeal to
this audience they knew this audience
existed before it just wasn't really
financially viable for them to try and
appeal directly to queer people and
queer allies
because
it wasn't clear that the loss wouldn't
be way worse and that's the other thing
it's not necessarily that when they do a
calculus like that
that they're going
well are we going to lose more than we
gain it's how certain are we that we're
going to gain more because i guarantee
you even before we started getting queer
representation in major pieces of media
there was
like the companies would have been on
the fence because they would have been
thinking like okay we're going to gain
something definitely
but are we certain it's going to be more
because if if we're in a maybe maybe not
area let's not do it because honestly
companies by and large are very
risk-averse if they can help it that's
something that's going to come up a
couple times over the course of this
conversation but that's the first thing
that's in the mix definitely not the
sole determining factor
but it's definitely in there now
somewhat related to that we've had the
ways in which different media functions
a little bit differently what i'm mainly
talking about here is how
tv
is way more inclusive than progressive
than films are this is actually
um usually been the case but the
divergence of that that gap has widened
in recent years and there's a reason for
that tv as time has gone on has become
increasingly niche
not necessarily by design but definitely
by necessity so you see when i was a kid
anyone who wasn't well off enough to be
able to afford cable because most people
i knew growing up didn't have cable they
had in their home probably five channels
abc cbs nbc pbs and fox
and it meant that pretty much anybody
who didn't have cable which was the
majority of people they were all
watching from the same relatively small
pool of stuff so things had to be
broadly appealing
but now as time has gone on and
initially with cable and very
specialized channels and now with
streaming and algorithms micro targeting
certain demographics
yeah tv can get really niche
and as a result
it actually is worth taking more chances
because if something like
netflix or hulu or whatever
wants to make a very queer friendly show
the algorithm is going to help ensure
that that is really only put in front of
the eyes of queer audiences like some
conservative people will still find out
it exists and get annoyed but it's not
the same as like back in the 80s or 90s
when major networks started putting any
of that kind of material on there
because that was being seen by people
who were definitely not okay with it
that was guaranteed that it was going to
be seen by people who did not want to
see it so it was a bigger risk to do
back then
not so much now
there's other reasons that tv tends to
be more progressive and you get more not
only instances of representation in tv
and streaming but you also get way more
queer creators you get much deeper
characterizations way less tokenism
and a big part of that has to do with
the fact that there's less money
involved in tv and streaming not
necessarily collectively but on a
per-project basis it costs less it makes
you less but it also costs less the cost
of a season worth of television is
not that much especially compared to
something like a true proper hollywood
big budget movie and part of the things
that help mitigate that is with
television you don't need necessarily a
big name star
or a big name director you can
swing a bat with a smaller budget on
more out there ideas or new voices or
actors who are unknown and are also
consequently significantly cheaper again
it's that sort of uh risk assessment
there's less financial risk involved in
television and plus there is so much
content constantly demanded by streaming
services especially at this point that
you are never ever going to come off bad
by just having more stuff out there for
people to find worst case scenario it
doesn't do well you don't get a second
season you try something else it's not
really a thing that a failed tv show
could sync a studio or a streaming
service
movies on the other hand
are
historically and now again even more so
significantly more expensive and
historically a big enough bomb
can kill a movie studio now that
specifically isn't really going to
happen now disney warner brothers sony
even paramount universal they are too
big
one bomb wouldn't kill them but one bomb
will cause them to have to massively
change their plans and reorganize things
because they really thought it was going
to be good and we've seen that in action
in the last few years with major
planned shifts that had to happen after
the underperformance of things like the
amazing spider-man 2
justice league that version of the mummy
with tom cruise that was supposed to
start the dark universe yeah
things can still go off the rails and
part of the reason for that is that at
this point especially
streaming for as much as it's good for
has kind of killed the mid-budget movie
and what i mean by that is pretty much
anything released by the big
entertainment companies at this point
is a big-budget
tempo probably franchise
piece of work
historically
there have almost always been big budget
temple
films but there also used to be
more in the middle stuff i mean you've
had your indies your cheap stuff but in
the middle
you know in today's money 20 to 40
million dollar budget
you had your dramas
you had your thrillers you had your
mysteries and some of these genres have
almost entirely disappeared from movie
theaters and exist almost exclusively on
streaming
because
the studios only want the biggest
returns now that means that they're
shelling out for the biggest budgets for
their movies but that's what gets them
the biggest returns that's your marvel
movies your dc movies your star wars
mission impossible etc etc now the
reason i bring up the money involved is
because there's more money on the line
this is another part in addition to the
increasing niche nature of streaming
that these studios are more reluctant to
put something in a film
because in a film
they need it to appeal to way more
people these are all what are called
four quadrant films they are intended
and really kind of need given their
budgets to appeal to the four major
quadrants and demographics at least some
degree if not as completely as possible
and
it makes sense these things when they're
successful make the most money
but
again
it's that risk aversion
with more money on the line
it's going to make studios
less willing
to put something like queer
representation
in a film
there's too much at stake
why risk it here
now related to the money
is something that i have talked about
before actually kind of explicitly and
that is the international market
i still to this day see people claiming
well you're never going to get queer
representation because of china now i
did a video years ago
debunking the china argument in specific
and i stand by everything that was in
that video here's the very short recap
yes it is true that china because it is
a totalitarian system and they control
all the media that comes in will not
allow for queer representation in movies
that are shown in that country
however
all that means is they recut them
they just remove it
so that actually doesn't work as an
argument to not include queer
representation at all because you're
just gonna cut it out heck
they released bohemian rhapsody in china
that is a
very gay movie
they took out 18 minutes i'm sure it's a
far worse movie for it but they still
released it there
now there is still an offshoot in the
problem that comes with it because even
if
studios actually did what i now consider
to be kind of the bare minimum which is
to put in representation and then cut it
out for the chinese release
well that does tend to result in very
token and disposable representation
things like
single scene instances or blink or
you'll miss it things between characters
who i'm not even sure they even have
names
and that is
token
i'm not going to say that's completely
meaningless i am the kind of person who
would argue i would rather have that
than nothing
like
people will say like well you're never
happy well like look
when that's what i'm getting
you're basically giving me expired gruel
but if i'm starving i'll take the
expired gruel but i am going to complain
about the fact that it's expired gruel
so
you know
it is kind of a situation where i do
think something even token removable
representation is better than nothing
especially at the point we are in this
country where there is such a fervor
over queerness trans people especially
that normalizing
queerness it it's
it's really becoming uh
a need a societal societal need but i
won't dig too far into that because
that's getting into the morals and as i
said companies don't have them so
heck with that and now even beyond china
with the international market like the
international market does matter don't
let anyone tell you otherwise however it
is worth pointing out that most studios
tend to make less on the international
market even if the international box
office is more because a lot of places
outside the u.s they either have to take
a smaller percentage as dictated by the
government as in the case of a place
like china or they have to work with
local distributors who take a cut and so
there is less of a cut to be able to be
taken by the studio releasing it
basically the u.s still tends to be the
single most important market not only
because a it's the biggest single market
but b
studios tend to get the biggest piece of
the pie there but international markets
do matter and the chinese market even at
a lower percentage is very big and i
understand the need to appeal there
especially when they're dropping this
much money per movie and these movies
have to make
so much insanely high amounts of money
back which i would say that's a problem
but that's also the reality in which we
live in i'm not going to pretend
otherwise but even outside of china
there are some countries where
yes it's true
if they know that there was queer
representation in any version of this
movie they won't play it
because they think that is wrong china
is you is a little bit unique in that
they just don't want the queer
representation on their soil in their
theaters they don't really care what
gets shown in american theaters there
are some other countries conservative
and often religiously minded countries
that do care and won't allow a picture
in even if it's recut if they know it
has queer representation elsewhere but
simply put the countries that do that
are not a massive piece of the market
and i for one would argue or at least i
would hope that the boost you'd get from
any kind of queer inclusion would be
higher than the loss of just those
specific markets but yes i do need to
emphasize and acknowledge the fact that
international markets do have an impact
on
the type of representation we get if not
its very existence in the first place
again i don't really accept it as an
excuse to not put it in at all but it is
affecting the shape of it and the slow
progression of things
but then there's the fourth thing which
is the thing i haven't seen anybody else
bring up as yet
which is the interconnectedness of media
at this point what do i mean by that
well
thankfully we seem to have moved past
the point where everybody's trying to
make their own version of the mcu
you know dc is still doing their best to
move forward sony has seems to have
realized that their only hope is to tie
a bunch of stuff kind of to the mcu
through spider-man and universal gave up
the dang uh
dark universe my gosh
but even if they're not doing literal
interconnected universes these companies
want
big
franchises
it's not enough to have
a big film
a big name
a big single franchise either they want
multi-layered multi-tiered franchises
marvel kind of being the golden child of
this but star wars is another big one
and dc and maybe one of these days if we
can ever get a video game movie that
doesn't suck we'll see things branch out
from something like mario but the thing
is
these things being interconnected
actually could in theory
make it harder to bring representation
even in the side pockets of it here's
what i mean by that so take something
like the mcu the first bit of queer
representation we had
that was from a character that anybody
cared about
was the lineup that implied that loki
was bisexual you're a prince
must have been
would-be princesses
or perhaps another prince
abyss of both again
first instance
not in the movies
but here's the thing
even though that happened on this show
on the side on a streaming service
theoretically
that shouldn't have a massive impact
elsewhere
except
we are in this
infuriating culture-war narrative at
this point where
the interconnectedness
might theoretically mean that somebody
who is angered enough
by that
acknowledgment of bisexuality in loki
it might not just be
that they don't watch that show
because it is part of the mcu
they might decide i'm not going to watch
any of this stuff now because the whole
thing's tainted to me if they're really
hardcore they might go so far as to say
nor will i watch star wars and i'm going
to kill my disney plus subscription
because it's all under the same company
disney owns it produces it streams it
and so
one instance
theoretically could turn somebody off
the entire company brand now does this
actually happen
it's really hard to judge
there are certainly people who will
often claim this sort of thing you know
they'll claim oh disney totally tanked
themselves by doing this everyone's
gonna abandon it most indications is
that's not true my point here is not so
much that this does happen
but that it becomes a new added concern
in the mix on top of and basically
amplifying
the alienating of audiences concern
where now
just doing something off in its own show
because a little sideshow isn't just a
little sideshow anymore a little
sideshow that is you know its own little
niche thing
happens to also be connected to the mcu
or the star wars or to dc movies or
whatever
almost nothing is standalone anymore
and the things that are standalone don't
get as big a push again lower budgets
lower notice
but as much as possible
new shows are going to try to be tied to
these big massive expansive franchises
which means that there's a potential
domino effect one additional thing about
the interconnectedness that occurred to
me while i was editing this while it may
not be true that these studios are
concerned about the domino effect that i
described there is the possibility that
they could start using that
interconnectedness as an excuse to not
have more inclusion in the movies their
first definitive inclusion of a
non-heterosexual character was in loki
and because of the interconnectedness
they can now claim the mcu has queer
representation even though it's been
done off in the side in a part of the
franchise that is not going to be seen
by as many people and that could
possibly be used as an excuse to not
include it in the movies which has a
much bigger audience it probably doesn't
help that the biggest inclusion in the
movie so far was in the eternals which
underperformed and not a lot of people
liked this is one of those we're gonna
have to wait and see how it pans out
things but part of me does worry that
this is going to be something relegated
to more niche media which actually has a
precedent as you can go through old
novels and comic books related to things
like star wars star trek and find way
more out there ideas and oftentimes more
progressive ideas that would not be
integrated into the main thing
so to recap
why is representation moving forward so
slowly
well
money
and the desire to make as much money as
possible and to avoid any
thing that might reduce
the amount of money that is brought in
ultimately but in terms of what i've
talked about today
concerns about aliens alienating a
certain portion of the audience and
whether that audience is large enough
that the gains elsewhere will counteract
it the complicating factor of massive
sprawling franchises where suddenly
ticking somebody off in one show might
make them drop a whole bunch of stuff
instead of simply not taking part in
that one particular thing
international markets some of which
really will not allow this kind of stuff
in and others who want it to be easily
removable resulting in less
representation in general and way less
substantive representation and all of it
even worse in film because while tv
continues to become more niche films are
becoming only bigger more bloated and
need to make more money appeal to more
people with every single release
why is representation so slow to get
better
concerns discussions and
worries about all this
that's why
will it keep getting better
probably
i mean we've seen with things like the
pushback on disney and the don't say gay
bill that
rolling back is
definitely not in their interest
but that again is probably part of why
they move forward as slowly as they do
because they seem to realize that once
they've established a certain baseline
of support
they can't really go back
because once they go back they are stuck
in that place because if you initially
show some support and some
representation for a queer audience but
then roll that back not have any or in
fact start demonizing that uh that
audience and giving the impression you
don't care about them
that audience is going to remember that
audience is going to feel betrayed
and you probably won't win the back not
for a very long time
so
one final factor
in all this
sliding back
that
carries some serious
serious backlash
and
they're seeing it
so every step forward
is very calculated
because they can kind of only move in
the one direction
unless they want to totally upend
their general image of becoming more
inclusive it's one of those things
that's weird
conservative audiences will probably
take back
a brand or a company or a franchise
that
even if it previously supported
queer people if it rejects them outright
conservative audiences will probably
take it back
because they'll consider that a victory
and a win like oh you saw this as a
mistake good for you
but
those of us on the other side of these
issues who believe in the importance of
representation
starting to give it to us
and then renouncing it
yeah no we're uh
we're not ever going to trust you again
not that we should trust you in the
first place you're a corporation you
have no
morals
that's the main thing i want you to
remember in all this corporations
despite the legal fiction that exists to
treat them otherwise are not people they
have no morals
and yet i have to keep talking about
them because they control way way too
much
and i'm just trying to be a pop culture
channel
anyways
what are your thoughts on all this
whatever your thoughts are
drop something down the comments let's
talk about it patreon is how i am able
to do this as my living any amount that
you can support me with is of immense
help
and there are rewards for every tier
everything from early access to certain
videos such as this one voting poll
seeing the docket at the start of each
month
but um even if you can't support me that
way
like share subscribe check out links to
other things i do like on twitch or tick
tock or what have you
but
don't worry
too much about it what i want you to
remember is
that you are beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey end credits time which means i need
to shout out some patrons this time i'm
going to be shouting out robin moore
zubin lutfalla turak oliver b melinda
walters
the oath the boy tt for knobby lax the
poodle zach paul idoln tracy scrappet
vincent paul bartolucci angry casper
toku bl whovian adam rdl taylor shane
ross shaylee gourley and brendan larose
you want to hear me mispronounce your
name check out rewards on the patreon
thanks for all your support
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]